we're gonna get the game started in
around 30 seconds so we know that
oh it's going okay there we go
so uh e4 e5 knight f3
is this what you expected so far
i think so far yeah i think pretty much
okay okay oh no he didn't play knight f6
did he okay okay good ludwig does not
take the pawn i was very worried we
might see a repeat of one of his uh
previous games where knight takes the e5
who to play knight takes e4 but okay at
least at least xuc um we'll have a
chance here to defend his pawn which he
should defund with his knight or with
his pawn here
right it seems like both players very
played very quickly not thinking about
the move order too much bishop before he
goes for instead okay um did he do any
prep on this that you know of
no i mean i'm i'm in the dark like
everybody else i i i have no inside
information in terms of what xcc has
done its preparation
so okay so ludwig plays knight d5 which
is a reasonable move probably it's going
to keep going hopefully there are no
blunders at the very start of the game
uh right
he played it very quickly actually um
which would be strange if it's the first
time he's seen this move to play so
quickly
he doesn't want to make a mistake too
early in the opening
right agreed so i'm a little bit
surprised by this opening choice from
ludwig it doesn't feel very natural and
it's definitely not the correct way to
play this so
i'm kind of wondering if ludwig is
feeling a little bit of nerves here in
this opening phase of the game because
it just it feels like he's moving a
little bit too quickly um in a position
where this definitely is not something
that is known
right
um okay so this is still a position
though where he can make some pretty
intuitive moves c3 i like because he's
going to support d4 in the future as
long as ludwig takes out his light
squared bishop and is able to castle
then he'll probably get out of the
opening just fine but so will xqc
right exactly so i mean i think the
thing is here actually has to be a
little bit careful here with this next
move whether whether to move the bishop
to uh to c5 or to a5 um potentially
white can make a queen check
um after you move the bishop back but
i still like this opening choice for xqc
this looks this looks pretty good
right i mean um bishop a5 queen a4 check
that's starting to look very tricky
there because then xqc would have to
block with the pawn and protect his
bishop with the queen but there there is
a chance that he would okay so he plays
bishop c5 which is definitely the safer
move so he doesn't have to worry about
that threat
right very very good move by actually
see here ludwig should play d4 which he
does play okay
um so far both players i feel like are
playing playing good moves um
both players are playing this quite well
so i think uh i think the position is
very balanced but it's important
for xqc i think more so than
than um ludwig to finish the development
of his pieces because that bishop knight
and rook are on their original squares
so it's uh okay this i do not like
however pawn takes pawn because now
black can make a check with the bishop
and you have these two pawns which i
think actually see would say they're
stacked which are um
not not ideally placed here
well let's take a listen on xqc stream
and see what he's talking about
he has a foreign
he actually is
all right well i i think our the audio
is a little bit scuffed on xqc so we're
just going to come back to the game now
um xqc goes for the check i actually
like his position here now because
ludwig has the two doubled pawns in the
center that's going to be a weakness
later on and bishop d2 is actually going
to help xqc trade that bishop off that
may have been at some risk of getting
stuck otherwise right exactly so
um yeah xcc has played a very good game
so far he definitely needs to trade the
bishops though it's
there's really no other move that makes
sense other maybe a queen check
but i i'd be surprised if he doesn't
doesn't trade the bishops here because
it's obviously the the correct move to
play he is hovering over his queen okay
he just played bishop takes d2 so he
certainly took both into consideration
and he saw that as the best choice if he
castles here it gets his king to safety
then he's also preparing a rook on e8
check right away oh okay queenie seven
check instead completely reasonable move
here uh i like everything that xcc has
done so far and um
yeah it's anyone's game at the moment
okay um well
i think we can take a listen on ludwig
see what his thoughts are on the opening
so far
might just be castle castle here
he is very focused
both sides have castle so that's nice
they're both in safe positions i like
that they've made it out of the opening
they're both solid because it seems like
it's been a very level game so far
yeah i would agree with that certainly
at this point it's very level both
players have uh developed their kings
the one thing that i would say for xcc
again is one thing that he needs to
remember is he has to get those three
pieces into the game
so i like my position because this
knight can only go really in one spot
[Music]
okay wait hold on i'm thinking if i go
here he trades i
i take with my bishop but if i go here
he takes i take
then i have tempo so i think that's a
good move nice nice thought process
there
i love how he paused the music to think
right right yeah he's doing very well so
far i really like his uh his position at
the moment and um
and i think
i think that in general i want to play
h3 anyway very well
one issue i would say here i think his
response would just be the position is
simplifying in a way where all the pawns
are pretty stable for both both players
so i'm not i'm not so sure that
uh
that it's gonna be easy for either side
to come up with concrete plans to try
and win this game because the pawns are
very very stable here it's gonna be hard
to make make blunders and lose lose
pieces this pawn is sick though true
this is a
fire pawn
hot hot hot i will say though xqc being
three minutes down on the clock is a
little bit worrying because we know that
was an issue for him before like in his
game against hutch and even if he has a
an even position in in a
end game where he's down on time oh he
blundered oh he could have taken the
knight
oh my gosh
well let's see if either of them correct
it
oh yeah yeah okay so now ecstasy has to
take the knight
he must have takes
he's under pressure from uh from a rook
he'll have to move
uh his only real options
i guess he could go super aggro no he
couldn't he can't go on this file at all
um
okay so they trade the bishop so now xcc
is out of danger again
so actually is back out of danger and um
and now the position is very it's a very
dry kind of position here i think that
that objectively white is better but
it's going to be very hard for ludwig to
prove an advantage because of the
placement of the pawns and just the
general fact that the knights are easier
to move than bishops uh they're just
easier pieces to see the moves with like
the ideas with bishops are much more
um they're they're much trickier i would
say than with a knight
yeah i think it's fair i just
also would add that the clock is
probably going to be the most important
factor moving forward so hopefully xqc
is trying to think on ludwig's time and
if we see him playing a little bit
faster then that will definitely
increase his chances of winning or
holding this game
right i would definitely agree with that
assessment uh i do like though again xqc
one of the main issues he's had playing
chess is finishing the development of
his pieces and again in this game it
looks like he's going to be able to get
his rook from 8 into the into the center
of the board to e8 and um and just play
the game of chess all the development
completed and then we'll see who comes
up with the better ideas okay so so
bishop g4 i like it's it's a good move
um it attacks the queen
now here at xcc should play queen to b5
attacking this pawn on d5 and putting
pressure on b2 even if it's protected
for now but right you know leveling
yeah even f5 i think is a good move here
too so many very good moves and he goes
for f5 so that's definitely more
aggressive and um i see that we actually
have his stream that we can bring up as
well so let's do that
i bet you i i bet you a couple marbles
and he did not think about the pawn he
just didn't think about it
he just didn't think about it
because then it takes takes and i'm kind
of half developed and my file here is
fully open
that is a fully open
juicer and then i can do
tricks like this
bing
bop
bim bop and lose -2 because i'm stupid
think about it
he seems very relaxed
a little too relaxed with his time
situation the problem
is pretty cog um i would say though
again the position is easier for him to
play
very much
that's the one thing i like to be in
because i'm gonna have to do um suicides
to uh to help like the king later on
caffeine kicking in now over here
and they do um
yeah it's a bad it's gonna be a bad
thing that's gonna be bad i don't like
it
yeah move back to the shadows that's
what i thought
now i can force right here
very good
because your hair sherman did you have
that i know you cut my hair how about
that what if you cut my own certain
i don't mind that trade that's very good
if i traded him i put to my balance and
if betrays me it puts me into balance so
i'm okay with it
he's developed all his pieces he car
this is really a great okay this is my
queen isn't it isn't it
yeah to put this guy into position it
takes me two moves if i do this it only
takes him one move
no no no no no no no no no no do this
there's a position i do this introduced
you can do whatever but if i do this
instead
take him two moves in the position if we
needed to
i will take with the queen i think
but nothing to defend my file though or
my rank
yeah nothing's under my rank
it's gotta move though an interesting
way of thinking about it
yeah you're right he's under four
minutes i obviously uh we would say take
with the rook you usually want to bring
your rook's open files but it's
interesting to see his thought process
right and i think he's doing completely
fine
yeah yeah his position is very
comfortable here um but i haven't heard
him talk about the time situation yet
which worries me because he'll if he
isn't paying attention to it he's not
going to try starting to move faster
already
right exactly yeah so i mean he just
needs to be careful with the time but
he's
but yeah he is playing very well so far
so um hopefully a good move for ludwig
he could also put his rook on c1 um he
could bring it on the open file i think
if ludwig does natural developing moves
here and keeps the time advantage uh he
he's looking like a favorite in this
match yeah
yeah i mean look it's hard though to
come up with ideas here uh for white
because this is a very kind of dry
position very few pieces on the board so
ideas are going to be fairly hard to see
for both sides
right
yeah i mean moves like a3 which you know
hold an imper important purpose not
letting the knight go to b4 if you ever
move the queen but they're very quiet
moves that you know you wouldn't expect
people to see so so quickly
right i mean i think here it's very hard
to see anything except for the open e
file for both players so that's why
that's why i think um in general
it's it's a position that i think might
be a draw if the time evens out here um
thinking for a long time as well because
the ideas are not obvious there's
nothing really clear-cut here it's even
material even number of pawns just a
very tough position to play for both
those players without many ideas right
and that's why ludwig goes for rookie
one so he's offering off the trade xqc
takes immediately
which is nice he made a fast move here
um do you think an idea like king f7 and
trading off queens is something that we
might see xqc go for here that would be
very very good i think the real danger
here is that xqc might try to bring his
queen to attack the poncer on the queen
side of the board
um and that would that's kind of the
real danger that i see here whereas he
really needs to keep his queen close to
his king
right because if the queen were to take
on d4 or a2 then all of a sudden the e8
square isn't defended anymore and ludwig
can just come in with checkmate
right exactly yeah oh well that would be
tough let's take a listen also on uh
ludwig's stream see what he's saying
again
pretty much newspaper at this point it's
so worn in
okay he's focused again just
quiet sigh here
queen e6 is also a good idea if uh
excuse me yeah this is a danger i was
worried this would happen between 84
that's exactly what i was worried about
yeah oh it was just played yeah wow
let's see if ludwig
sees the queen eight future threat
even queen e6 is kind of scary
if he takes this pawn oh he saw it there
you go
so i guess i have to do something like
like this
just something that doesn't matter at
all
and then hope that he he takes
this pawn he's trying to bait him on
and then i win
this was a throwaway move
to bait it this is actually pretty funny
because the only thing protecting this
right now is his queen
but if he moves his queen
off of a4
then we're in business
okay so elise sees it okay
yeah so xqc makes space for his king so
it looks like he might know this move i
don't like from ludwig at all now queen
takes pawn
okay now it's getting very tricky
yep
white is still pro white is still
probably much better here but it's it's
getting tricky
why is that not me and uh
and that's what you want to go for
especially when you're low on the time
situation because maybe he'll be able to
trap ludwig and get a bishop up or
something like that with a double check
right right i mean the danger here for
ludwig is the pawn on f2 is hanging
so he needs to bring his queen back and
defend it oh don't take the pawn because
queen takes ff2 is kind of scary after
even though bishop g2 works but
yeah i mean this is a tough spot to be
in for both players um i still think i
would prefer to be white objectively um
considering the the situation the danger
of the black king but very very hard for
uh for both players to play this
correctly here and i think we could see
a repetition potentially um
but the key here that xc needs to be
aware of is that the white bishop cannot
become an act of peace here you need to
leave
leave the bishop and then bring your
knight to the center of the board
right
um yeah his his knight is
on a6 so it's not a great square so he's
basically playing right now with just a
queen versus a queen and a bishop but if
he starts activating his knight bringing
it in say a square like c5 then he'll be
able to hop into the attack soon and
could be a lot more dangerous or you
know even a defending piece in the
future
exactly yeah
oh ludwig sees the f2 pawn and it looks
like he's gonna play queen e2 this is
not a move that i like um
again i think i mean it's very hard
looking at this as a strong chess player
to to sort of step step back and look at
it from their point of view um
the problem for ludwig here is that i
think xuc can trade the queens off at
some point with queen to e5 check and if
he does that he's gonna be ahead by uh
by one pawn and it'll be a knight
against bishop which which should be um
easier to play
i i'm just not sure if xqc will see that
with his limited time and i do like the
fact that ludwig found one of the
scariest threats and he defended it just
from uh
although now black people
xqc has now activated his knight as well
and he's he's up a pawn
so he does have a better end game here
he's under two minutes on the clock but
all of a sudden ludwig is is lower on
time as well right yeah so i like
everything that xcc is doing here this
is a fantastic position for him
um
i'm not really sure what lead we can do
this is very unpleasant because black
can put a knight on the dark square in
front of the pawn and the double pawns
are really in bad shape for white
well let's listen on xqc
yeah this is a good move i kind of like
this this gives me kind of like a for a
cool fork here dude
well that's a kind of a cool fork i kind
of like that i this idea this kind of
seed idea that develops it starts as
some like a small worm but then it comes
it becomes cocooned
and then folded them into that butterfly
did
i had the progression of it that's
intense
that's inspirational dude
so artsy
oh no he took oh no
oh no xcc should win the game now i
think okay now what
how how good are xqc's uh end games from
what you've seen so far my king my king
is safe so i mean i what i've seen from
xqc in general is um
is that he uh
is that he tends to be pretty good when
the time gets low and it's fairly small
i can start doing something like this
i
think
okay so mike
f6 check um
so i guess yeah you can move you can
move the king back um
really the thing here for xcc is that he
keeps making the moves quickly right
so so yeah so you should be
okay quick check my discovery
i move pawn
demoretsky's engaged king g8 and now if
one would play queen to g6 there will be
queen to f7 or queen to e5 which are
both winning for black and i do expect
ludwig to play queen to g6 here if it
looks like an obvious move um to to
create threats against that that that
that might be the game
that might that might be the devil's
been winning and losing because then my
king lost one position i would also say
here's my disposition it feels like
um in terms of um
in terms of positions it's just fun okay
so he does it okay
so queen e5 or queen of seven
come on i don't understand it and give
me checkmates come on felix queen of
seven come on clean up seven
for queen e5 come on clean up seven or
queen e5
he's hovering come on do it do it man do
it and then you grab the
wow very nice
and and if he trades off the queens
i can force trade it because he's just
going to be up two pawns after he also
takes up six so it should be easy to win
ludwig should try to keep the queen on
and he can't he can't adjust
he can't put more pressure here with
anything it's all too far
and i have my king in range for pressure
so i have one two three four four power
pressure and he has two he loses 100
he has to get out
actually take it out he's fully
committed all right so now you can take
with the queen
ludwig also under two minutes on the
clock now mm-hmm this is good this is
very good and i ended up two
and i could also see something queenie
king h7
i could see queen eight king h7 queen e4
to hit the king in the pawn and then
queen g6 would actually win the game
um
so yeah i'm king h7 of course here by
xuc just move the king
okay just gotta move guys gotta go king
h7 and then block with the queen
okay this move i don't like i thought if
he moved the king up he would have
actually won the game almost for sure
because there would have been a queen
check by
by ludwig there so so okay i don't
really love this move but nonetheless
he's good just move the king okay clean
up seven
yikes
yeah he's he's giving up the d-pawn here
that's a little concerning he should he
should try to keep the b6 seems like a
really safe move here right but i would
hope that he okay he plays it okay good
move
so move the king of course
because if he moves the queen then he's
also losing a7 okay perfect moves the
king away
wow this is going to be
hopefully an interesting finish i mean
if ludwig moves his queen back and he
has and he sees that way to trade off
queens then he should be winning with an
extra pawn
right yeah this is going to be a really
interesting finish to the game i mean
ludwig is actually down on time now as
well he has less time than xqc
um
oh this is intense okay so lettery goes
for a4 i think he's just not sure how to
continue here right but the pressure is
on xqc to force and win um
well now he's going to be at risk of
perpetual checks because his king is
more open yeah i don't think either
player here knows what they're doing um
i think i think it's whoa hikaru wow
players need to well this is this is i
mean this is a very hard position to
play for both players what i hope is
that neither player blunders their queen
this is really the thing i could see is
you accidentally like make a check and
you leave a queen under attack i totally
could see something like that happening
here so um this is just gonna be very
hard i think as players both players are
gonna have to play on tempo and hope
that the other guy misses something
that's what they're gonna have to do
here
um and now unfortunately after queen d6
there is no queen g6 check anymore so
this is going to be
this is going to be tough for both
players i don't even know what to make
of this honestly i think this game could
go either way even though black is extra
pawn
i think this might be a draw actually
the more i look at this the more i think
this might just be a draw right because
i mean well literally the only thing is
he spent 30 seconds on his last move
that's a lot of time obviously almost
like 50 of his time here so hopefully he
he used that time to think of a plan and
if he sees that he could just keep
repeating the checks then he'll get a
draw
yeah i think this might be a draw i and
i don't even know what to make it's just
so hard to play for both players
i think he's going quicker he's got a
little quicker ludwig is moving way too
slowly here but he saw the the the key
move here so yeah
oh no
he didn't go for the drone oh no oh no
oh no okay whoa but you can take the
pawn
oh my gosh what's going on now queen g2
check is coming in pawn to each two also
oh my gosh luigi checkmate checkmate
queen g2
oh my god
wow
um
oh my god what a throw
by ludwig he had a draw i think he
the thing is when you're solo on time
like 20 or 30 seconds you shouldn't try
to go find new ideas he had one idea and
he could have just tried to stick to it
it almost seemed like he was going for a
win actually yeah i mean i think ludwig
ludwig is the favorite of this match but
i think he let the pressure get to him
there and he just i mean he just he got
too aggressive and
wow i mean just wow i don't even know
what to say that was so amazing um
crazy crazy um but yeah it's one nothing
now game two coming up ludwig actually
is a black piece which i think is not to
which is definitely gonna be make it
much more difficult um to win this match
but i'm
you know as i've said before i think one
of the things that's most inspiring is
the way you see the progression the way
people have improved and to see excuses
play over the last probably
uh two to three matches compared to what
we had seen is um it's it's spectacular
and it's really made a lot of fun to
watch because a lot of mistakes he was
making even if he's still making some
mistakes are not the same kind of
mistakes and um yeah just amazing to see
really and the next game is going to
start in less than a minute so we're
going to see xqc with the white pieces
and ludwig with the black pieces there's
no break they're just going to go right
away and on that note let's take a
listen on ludwig as well see if he's
able to run the russian so i'll be right
back yeah sounds good
oh chat he's quiet
um hopefully he can recover
it's it's tough psychologically to have
to
go straight into it after
a checkmate like that
i can make this comeback
i'm confident
i can run it back and win it
he played out of his goddamn mind i
played a bit like a can
but i know what he wants
and his biggest thing
is trading
i should have capitalized i need to look
this was open
then he's in check he has a move free
pawns i need to see these things okay
apparently that was better but who cares
that's all right that's nerd [ __ ] okay
like big big big second game i know as a
fact we bring this back the alexander do
we know what the accuracy was with all
the knowledge
let's go back yeah so the accuracy was
like over 90 for xqc and or in the 40s
for ludwig xuc i think it was 93
accuracy wow yeah great game by xuc
they're fantastic he's such a proud dad
hikaru
i mean i i think you know yes i'm very
happy to see it but i think it's you
know as i say at the end of the day it's
not specifically like my doing you know
it is the players at the end of the day
who find the best moves and
to see xuc playing really playing a lot
better than he was before and i think in
many ways just relaxing after after
those first couple of games in the
bracket stage it certainly seems like
he's a much better player and he seems
much happier and he seems to be enjoying
it yeah in a way that i don't think he
was at the start of the event so just uh
really really happy for felix again the
match is not over there still is a
second game to go though and um and
anything can happen as we've seen and
ludwig looks actually a little bit
rattled if you look at him i i don't
think he was expecting
um expecting xucc to play this well he
definitely looks rattled um so it's
gonna be
it's gonna be a very interesting second
game in terms of what ludwig tries to do
it seemed a bit like he underestimated
xqc if you remember that moment when he
uh played king h2 trying to bait xqc
into falling for a maiden one he didn't
go for the most accurate move because he
didn't expect the best out of his
opponent and the game is on by the way
yeah
all right xqc white pieces he goes for
e4 he's probably going to play a scotch
like he always does
knight f3 d4
oh okay he goes for a rui lopez instead
bishop b5 and this is i think the most
commonly played opening at this stage
okay let me plays knight f6
okay this is kind of weird okay this is
just a very weird opening um
okay um
takes a night okay this is relatively
okay um
okay now ludwig takes the b-pawn which i
really don't like because now you can
play knight takes pawn
right so i i don't know what ludwig is
what ludwig is doing i i feel like he
was playing e5 in his main matches but
taking with the b-pawn is not the
correct move you're supposed to take
with the other pawn
and i it just seems like then he's
probably not familiar with this opening
and that's why he wasn't sure how to
recapture
right so um so yeah so i i guess like
it's
it's a little bit surprising to see this
from level because i know that i told
ludwig um quite a while ago now it's
probably well over a week but i told him
that you always take with the d pawn
towards the center uh do you take away
from the center in this one instance as
opposed to capturing towards the center
so i'm very uh
very surprised by this move from ludwig
um
yeah so he takes the pawn and it looks
like uh yeah so let's listen on xqc i
want to hear his thought process behind
deciding to take that pawn
still
is a good song
i think it is a jews dude
okay so he's playing faster too so he
won't be in as much time pressure i'm
not trying to take right
that's confusing
so here we go you can play d4 to protect
his knight or knight f3 and then
blocking i always hated this this is
right
you know what maybe to my games
we'll actually push the pump but we'll
see
because he's familiar with the d4
idea
i think he will push the pawn i'd
i'll protect and get out so i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna do this just gonna do
that
this still works
all right
now he's gonna take this for free it's
not ready for free
it's kind of for free not really
i think i think this is why it's called
a gambit
or something i think
in other openings that's why they call
it a gambit because yes you go plus one
at the beginning right but in a few
moves you'll lose it back but it opens
the other
tree of possibilities that you would
want and that that's what you want by
doing that with that opener so you want
the you want you want that small tree to
be opened up
and but in the end you still go out go
back to even
well he's already up a pawn actually so
it's a little better than than just a
gambit because even if he loses that
pawn back he already got the one on e5
first right he's right with his idea
that he is going to get a lot of peace
activity in return for losing the e4
yeah so i think at this point uh xcc
should move the knight back he can
capture the pawn as well but the danger
with capturing the pawn is that after
queen takes pawn it's not so easy to see
that you can block with your queen
right um because then you're pinning the
queen to the king and the queen can't
take the knight
but he did say that he just wanted to
get out of there so i can see him
playing a safer move like knight f3 or
or knight d3 which maybe is a little bit
less intuitive because it's not the
original square
and after he moves his knight back he's
still going to have to block with the
queen though because otherwise
i i guess he can make a move like bishop
e3 also
right i mean i i think the key though is
that he doesn't make a mistake here he
needs to move the knight here
um and it's very important that he moves
the knight back to f3 or to the d3
square
um and castle the king but yeah i think
certainly for ludwig the most important
thing here is staying calm and
understanding that he is still
objectively or he should be the better
player and not getting super rattle i
think i think you're right then last
game he kind of underestimated xcc and
he thought he was just going to win and
he could bait him into making making
falling for that checkmate which which
didn't work so
um so so yeah i think it's it's anyone's
game here if xcc finds the right moves
he should be significantly better but
it's going to be hard to follow the
fault to find these moves right well
let's get some insight on what ludwig is
thinking i'm curious if he changed his
approach in this game so we're going to
listen in on his stream
wait what
oh
no that's not a good idea
well
uh xqc just blundered a piece
also what is the song remix
ymca yeah yeah
like an electronic version
do you think leonard realizes that he's
winning now because i haven't heard him
say anything
about that
no i mean i think right now he's just
very very serious
and fun song remixes i mean he can even
stop xqc's castle here if he wants by
playing a move like bishop a6
really that's a little bit too advanced
to find right here yeah nonetheless i
think um i think ludwig just needs to
figure out the right way to activate his
bishops if he does that i think he'll be
in very good
people putting d
mca
although he sees it he sees fish basics
here so um that's impressive
yeah i mean i i don't really like it
because you bring the fish back to a
square where i think he can get attacked
but nonetheless um
yeah i think
i don't know it
wait is this a ymca mixed with time
by wow
what a song choice i'm digging it
yeah right
um but no i agree with you sometimes
moves that are more simple and safe when
you're up a piece like moving his darts
for bishop to castle would have been the
safer choice
right but [ __ ] basically is a great
move here it's a fantastic move to play
um
so i mean i think i think probably
ludwig is going to win this game most
likely is my guess um
but
who knows who knows i think it's any
anyone anyone's game here
right and if xqc wants to try to be
tricky he can play something like queen
a4 here but then ludwig does have bishop
b5 which defends the bishop and the pawn
at the same time and keeps the white
king from being able to castle yeah i
mean i think this is already very very
difficult for xqc to play here um
just being down this one bishop i think
i mean it's it's hard to
it's hard to find find find good moves
um yeah he goes knight two now of course
ludwig can just take the pawn on this d4
square and probably go on to a pretty
smooth victory if he does that but yeah
right he can also develop his bishop and
just make sure he's gonna castle i i
feel like he has quite a few moves here
that are fine
yeah yeah i think i mean i think uh it's
yeah it's
tough position for xuc here very tough
position
yeah
i mean
those quick moves in the opening where
he blundered it it really gave his
chances away do you think it was because
he played too quickly
um no i mean i think he was just he was
unfamiliar with it and he didn't want to
retreat the night
but but as i said before one of the
biggest things that xuc has done in
general and um
in these games that i really like is he
is actually using every piece that he
has it's not where he's simply using
only one side of the board he brings his
knights he's bringing his rooks into the
game that already i think is a very big
improvement over what we have seen from
him in in earlier stages of this event
yeah i i think it's fair to give credit
there he's made an improvement and he
also came back after that really tough
loss um against moist critical which is
even harder than just having to improve
your own chest because you also have to
get over
you know some
some psychological
bad feelings
right exactly so so yeah i mean i i
think uh it's it's definitely an
improvement i think he's probably gonna
lose this game
but i i really have no idea who the
favorites gonna be because xcc of course
has played a lot of bullet chests so he
knows how to play really quickly when he
wants to
um so i really don't have a have any
idea who the favorite's going to be
okay queen g4 so
that's more of an aggressive move um
he's also allowing himself to castle
queen side at some point in the future
it's good that
i i kind of like that move um he doesn't
really have any other pieces to develop
the only thing is he can't castle queen
side and keep protecting the f2 pawn
right exactly so
i mean objectively it's winning for
ludwig but again he has to find some
good moves here
um in order to win this game he looks he
looks far more serious and i've seen him
look at i think any other point in the
entire event um he just looks really
really really really stoic
yeah and both of them look very serious
we've just seen the players getting
increasingly more and more serious as
tournament gets on this is what chess
does to everyone they might be
entertaining streamers they just have to
sit down and focus so much at sometimes
all right he takes d4 that's a nice move
from ludwig he's opening up the center
when he's up a piece and his
opponent's king is in the center of the
board of course so is his so he is gonna
have to castle at some point right
exactly so so yeah i mean i think at
this at this point in time um
tough spot white should probably push
the pawn to c4 to try and get the king
out center of the board but at any rate
it's a very very difficult spot to be in
right and ledway can just grab that pawn
on d4 as well his queen is still going
to protect the g7
spot um and then the white king really
cannot castle on either side
i guess he can castle queenside it's
just very dangerous
this is a tough game but
if it does go to tie breaks he car with
304 matt who do you think is better in
short time control
um i think
i really have no idea i would think that
it should be ludwig but xuc has played a
lot of quick games
so i don't i don't know um
okay also i think you can tell how
nervous ludwig is because he he like
literally just got him and started start
started walking and i don't think i've
ever seen him do that before and
he just got up and started walking he
looks really really nervous so um i wish
we had a heart rate monitor on the
players
that would have been really fun we
should do that if we organized
blockchain right right exactly yeah i
mean he you can just tell that both
players are really really nervous so
okay so xcc castles which is the the
correct move maybe not correct me but
it's one of the best moves that he has
available in the position which doesn't
lose on the spot so
right even though this is ludwig's game
to win here bishop e5 for example i
think would win the game on the spot um
there still is a lot of uh or bishop a3
also is very strong um true but like
very hard to see because it looks like
right i think bishop e5 is not a very
hard move to see because you line up the
bishop and the queen to attack
um so if ludwig finds that move he'll
win on the spot i still think he's gonna
win he's winning on the board he's also
way ahead on the clock as well so to me
it seems very unlikely that xqc will
come back here unless there's
unless ludwig makes a huge mistake and
he is um drawing an arrow to e5 so we
might actually see it um okay well let's
take a a listen on xqc and see how he's
he's dealing with this position it seems
like he realizes he's losing here
ah he knows
that's okay
battle i had
oh my god
this is honestly a really nice game from
ludwig after he won the piece i mean
seeing a move like bishop a6
and bishop e5 that combination
very very nice job from ludwig honestly
right yeah that was a there was a very
good um very good opening from and
actually i think who gets
i assume ludwig gets white right in the
3-0 game because he did better in his
bracket he must have won one game i
think whereas actually lost all three so
i assume ludwig has has white in the in
the armageddon game unless i'm mistaken
right yeah that's uh what i'm being told
as well well we are gonna take a quick
break ladies and gentlemen we'll be back
soon with the tie breaks uh 3-0 time
control no increment ludwig with the
white pieces versus xqc with the black
pieces stay tuned
and we are back we are about to see the
tie break game between ludwig and xqc
they went 1-1
in the
classical format so the 10 minutes with
a five-second increment now they're
going to go down to just three minutes
no increment one game only hikaru
any ideas on
what the chances look like here for for
loading and xpc um
i mean i think it's very uh very hard to
predict i think a lot is going to depend
on the opening phase of the game if um
if if xuc can get out of the first like
10 moves without being in trouble i
think his chances to win this win this
game are very high um whereas if he ends
up in trouble right away i think he's in
bad shape and i would say for ludwig
it's really important that he presses
the uh
uh presses the advantage um
in the opening phase of the game
all right um well how much of a
advantage do you think starting off with
the white pieces is
um i don't think it's that big of an
advantage in a match like this um
but
uh but i think i think in general um it
really depends on the opening opening
setups that that both players have and i
think the fact that xqc maybe doesn't
have a stable of an opening setup could
potentially affect him in a very
negative way uh but i i don't think the
color makes any difference xqc is
warming up with some bullet he's trying
to get those fast clicks prepared oh
what are your thoughts on that
um i mean i think it's a good thing just
play a couple of quick games the only
danger to playing bullet chests if he
loses a couple of games then um then
he's going to end up maybe feeling a
little bit less confident so that's
really the danger and the only thing i
don't like about playing a couple games
bullet just
yeah that's that's very fair um and it
looks like he's going to actually lose
the bullet oh no he's about to get made
in his bullet game
okay well i guess he's going to be ready
for
the ludwig
game instead
all right
so here we go right yeah we have takeoff
e4 e5 knight f3 oh they're playing the
same thing as before and ludwig takes
the pawn i know oh why did i holy smokes
they're blitzing whoa whoa
whoa what's going on here did ludwig
just miss queen h5
i'm so confused by this whole game
i don't really understand what either
player is doing here actually okay so
bishop six here
that that could be the uh statement on a
game so far
um that was really fast this this is a
blitz game not a bullet game and now it
looks like
xqc is already lost
well you can play bishop to f6 it's a
very critical spot bishop to f6 is a
very important move that that xcc has to
play here
all right well um
let's listen in on um ludwig as well
wow
oh that was
fast
wait what wait he missed me he didn't
take the rook
oh no
he missed the checkmate what what what
the heck just happened
okay i mean he's still winning but it
wasn't it
it was it was an instant win there i'm
just gonna
backtrack real quick to show chat if if
he would have just taken the rook it
would have been checkmate i think he's
nervous i think they're both nervous
i'm really confused by this game it's
not gonna lie okay now white can take
the take the knight though yeah ludwig
should see this right
i mean yeah he sees it backwards
diagonal
well
um i mean queen d5 looks great here he
can also play queen f4
um
i just
he's up a full rook so even if he didn't
see the checkmate not just a full rook
sorry a full rook and three pawns
right but the thing is the time is what
matters so if xcc moves quickly here he
just starts moving really really fast i
think there is a chance for xuc to um
to survive potentially but he's gonna
have to win this game on time that's the
only way he wins this game right so so
king
f7 beautiful move by uh by by uh ludwig
very nice move and yeah now ludwig
should win the game
very very nice
well well let's listen oh whoops
wait what oh oh he went for the cheese
oh
he went for the cheese with rookie eight
i like that actually
that's the flag he's hoping for the flag
that's a good strategy to try yeah i
just gotta move fast you just gotta move
really fast okay but again i think i
think ludwig has a little bit too much
time here in order to uh in order to get
to
right
and what does happen if they they
somehow draw i assume they just play
another game of colors reverse probably
yeah that would make sense
but ludwig is yeah a lot of is cleaning
up the board here
true i mean there will still be some
chances for for stalemate or flagging
oh
it's like whoever wins obviously even
don't style me if the king can get stuck
in the center
okay
he's playing fast at least you know whoa
okay yeah
yeah and there you go almost a style
mate there though but ludwig wins
oh i
okay well ludwig is moving on
is going to be ludwig versus moist
critical i mean xqc had a really
impressive first game um
and you know the
the last two didn't quite go his way but
we've seen huge improvement from him as
well right exactly yeah i mean i thought
it was fantastic the way that xcc played
i thought he was a very big underdog in
this match and the fact that he actually
won one of the two one of the three
games um it says a lot about how much
he's improved uh so it's a big shout out
to xqc because certainly i did not
expect him to uh i really thought he was
going to be a very very much an uphill
battle the fact that he won one of the
three games is uh is very impressive so
nothing to uh nothing to to be ashamed
of i think the the improvement by xuc in
these last in this match especially and
the previous match against foosley it
was very noticeable so um even though
ludwig wins xucci certainly played great
chess and um and just somebody had to
win this match
the consolation bracket they are playing
for an extra thousand dollars for who
ends up winning it but it's more than
that it's also pride and feeling like
you were the winner and the entire
bracket i think that's a pretty big deal
you're damn right alex you're damn right
hi ludwig good to have you back what's
up how's it going hikaru i'm sorry i
killed your son
i hope that was all good you actually
played really well i was i was kind of
nervous there did you realize that you
almost stallmated xqc in that final game
like you came very close with the rook
and the night in the center there nope
didn't even cross my mind what happens
if a sailbank would go again
yeah i think so yeah but but you played
it well i guess the only question is in
the opening can you see the checkmate in
one here i just brought it up on the
board um great question yes i did see it
and this alex by the way you've been
using the term throwing for content a
lot this is called throwing for content
all right it's not losing and then being
the fart of twitch
it's extending it to entertain the fans
all right you think that game one
was was a real loss come on come on
although i will say his accuracy was out
of this world on game one
i mean yeah you you're really trying to
get that 40 accuracy for content right i
mean something like 50 or 60 wouldn't
have been enough you decided to go the
whole shebang well look i saw you play
four player chess and lose 15 times in a
rotohikaro and i thought hey let me hop
on this losing at chess for content game
you know what we won the last game
ludwig i'm sorry you didn't see that one
i i tuned out i tuned out the moment
you're ahead but happy i won happy you
got your job back
i know ludwig you were doing a fantastic
job at commentary and now you're playing
an incredible game up next you're going
against moist critical did you prepare
against him at all absolutely not i
haven't looked at him once i was only
worried about beating xqc and i think
the only reason i won is because i
looked i
nobody plays the aggressive knight is
that what you call them the right knight
on black the one that attacks your pawn
and then i just looked at it three
seconds before the match and you just
put the queen there so i haven't prepped
at all i hope i can do similar prep for
uh critical and beat him but
i'm trying to take the whole thing down
all right and do you feel like a
favorite going into that match
i i don't know man because he is daniel
nareditsky who i've heard is a greek god
with
washboard abs
and and no 17 languages so i'm a little
nervous about that my coach was hans and
he's a virgin so that's it's like
there's a difference here uh we're gonna
try our best at the end of the day
though
all right ludwig well always always a
pleasure having you on he car any last
questions there no i mean i just think
we really have enjoyed enjoyed all your
games and you seem to be playing
fantastic chess when it matters
especially in the last two games of this
match so just keep it up and uh and just
looking forward to another really fun
match between you and charlie thank you
appreciate that
all right well thanks for being here
ludwig good luck in your next game
[Music]